a boat trip through Homburg Harbor is
one of the Hanseatic cities main
attractions Homburg is the third largest
port in Europe the port was built in the
1870s
that's the period when the Freeport was
created within the port itself here hub
works merchants enjoyed the privilege of
storing refining and processing imported
goods duty-free
it was the birth of the Spiker stock or
warehouse district a kilometer and a
half in length workers used small boats
to bring cargo to the warehouses until
the 1960s it was mostly coffee tea and
spices but by the 1980s the Schweiker
stock had become the world's largest
transshipment point for oriental rugs
fourth-generation carpet dealer Parvez
on Bucky Lee has store rooms on the
fifth floor
he still moves his wares using rope
winches more than a hundred years old
that's not what it takes much longer
than loading pallets onto a truck with a
forklift but it has its charms
I was had no central in the warehouses
with their thick brick walls the climate
remains moderate all year round that
still works well today this leads to the
rear and our emergency exit that's more
than a century old via a fire escape
it's not well lit but it's still used
and serviced regularly I hope I never
need it nowadays and Vickie Lee looks
down at tourists below 20 years ago the
Spiker Scott was a world of its own this
was once a self-contained space they
were customs barriers everywhere and
ordinary people were afraid to come here
the barriers were removed in 2004 and
warehouse district became a huge tourist
attraction a million visitors come here
every year it's lovely
it's our second trip to Humber the
buildings are great and the colors are
different than in other cities it's
unique
in one warehouse that dates from 1888
the Shriker stock museum informs
visitors about the district's history
what's special about the spica stunt is
that it's a city of warehouses the
world's largest warehouse complex the
architects back then really designed it
as a city we actually had city gates yes
the Thames down on us there stuck to
what happened the warehouse district was
a huge project back then to city
districts were demolished about 16,000
people had to be resettled and new
canals were built the brick buildings
are attractive and functional and rest
on long wooden stakes in the 1920s
bordering the Freeport the merchants had
the contour House District built the
first dedicated office district in
continental Europe with gigantic
administrative buildings architect frets
huggers chill a house is world renowned
for its shape and brick facade this is
really something unique in a European
city that since the late 19th century
the center has developed into a city
itself a service sector district where
the population was replaced by
warehouses and offices lagann pupil
Heiser Frederick
the spire stat and contour house
district bear witness to more than 130
years of maritime trading history the
people of Hamburg are proud of them and
they're waiting expectantly for UNESCO s
decision